davey and clowny the first overall pick
in the 2014 draft has an unsigned
franchise tender and the indications are
he's going to show up later this month
get his full
amount whatever it ends up being there's
a grievance over whether it's going to
be almost 16 million or 17 million and
change but the bottom line is there are
some people who think that a trade could
happen should happen
there are many practical problems with
the trader jv and clowning first and
foremost he can't be signed to a
long-term deal because the july 15
deadline has come and gone anybody that
was interested in trading for genevieve
and clowney could have done it should
have done it would have done it before
july 15 so you sign him to a long-term
deal because as it stands you give up
value you get him for one year next year
his franchise tag would be 19 or 20
million that's his leverage that's his
starting point for a long-term contract
you're going to spend a ton of money to
keep the guy around if you want him and
if you don't want him you will have
given up something of value for a one
year arrangement with a guy that we
really don't know how healthy he's going
to be we really don't know how much he
has in the tank it's been a mixed bag so
far during his career and i can see why
no one is making a move for him maybe
the texans would be interested in moving
him but i don't see that there's anyone
that out there that is going to pounce
because they would have pounced during
the time where they could have turned
that trade into a long-term contract uh
agreed and the big issue here is the
knee i mean it's a guy that had a deal
he's got bone on bone issues there's no
cartilaginous knee i think that's really
ultimately what's holding back the
houston texans to wanting to sign him to
a long-term deal because this is on the
field mike he is one of those guys that
you know like i've talked about with
michael bennett or other players he the
the f the place that at the play up stat
i mean man you can go through a game and
you could watch the first 10 plays of
the game and go man jedevian connie's
not on the stat sheet but he ruined the
first seven plays of this football game
by just creating chaos or dominating his
guy and that's what's special about him
i just wonder
you know you you made all the points
would a team in the super bowl window
right now that feels like man we are
there we are good we got money
would they trade a third round pick and
then just take a flyer on one year and
go okay we'll pay them this money right
now for this year and see where it goes
and maybe they think about it and just
do it like almost like a baseball type
idea i'm just throwing that out there i
haven't like put in deep thought to this
but it just well curious to me you got
to have 16 million in cap space or 17
million in cap space if he wins that
grievance it's and you can't be it can't
be reduced you can't do anything to
extend that deal and push down the cap
number that's the problem if you're the
texans do you take a third round pick
for the guy now when if you let him walk
away as a free agent in march you get
most likely a third round compensatory
draft pick in 2021 it's got to be better
than a third round pick in 2020 to get
you give up the guy now because you
think the guy can help you now you just
don't want to pay him big money next
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports